when I was a child I thought I wanted to
be a scientist I could have been in
chemistry or physics or medicine at some
point in my college years I decided to
switch to economics when I was a junior
in college why did I make the switch I
don't exactly know I had a lot of what
struck me is that the choices young
people have to make about careers there
are so many things you can do but but
you are expected to commit at a very
early age to one line or another and I
think it's part of the tragedies of
ordinary living that you have to do that
I would love to be all of those things a
chemist a physicist the medical
researcher and how about a literary of a
writer as well but in reality you can't
do all of those things and you never
know you make a choice in life you never
know at the end whether it was correct